[Music]
coming up next our weekly series book
notes we spend the next hour talking
with susan mohler author of shooting war
photography and the american experience
in combat she is a lecturer in history
at princeton university
[Music]
susan muller this is the cover of your
book as you can see shooting war
photography and the american experience
of combat
what is this photograph on the cover and
why did you choose it
it's a photograph of a photographer it's
a self-portrait actually taken during
the vietnam war
in 1968 probably the
critical year during the vietnam war and
it seemed appropriate for the book
because
this is a book about war photography but
it's also a book about how war
photography came to
be so important to americans and so it
seemed important it seemed
interesting and
critical to have
that sort of duality
a
picture of a war
scene
that itself had the photographer in it
who's the photographer
named mccomb why'd you pick him
well i guess because he's one of the
critical photographers from the vietnam
war
is very important body of work
when did you first
say to yourself i want to write a book
about photography and war
well it happened when i was in graduate
school i was
at harvard
and had
been a photographer previously i had
been a photojournalist here in
washington dc
and when the kind time came to make a
decision about
what i wanted to write my dissertation
on the classic dilemma
i
actually sort of a funny story i spoke
to a number of the harvard professors
about not doing about war photography
but about doing
photography
as sort of social documentary
photography pictures that we might have
seen from the depression
and harvard said that sounds fine but i
had been
an undergraduate at yale university
harvard is as we all know one of the
best institutions in the country but
it doesn't have a single american art
historian and so i thought well perhaps
go back to my undergraduate institution
and find out
what that what the competition had to
say
so i went down to the competition and
they said well
this uh photography and social
documented photography subject sounds
good but
have you thought about war photography
and light bulbs went off and bolt of
lightning hit and i said yeah actually
that's that's a better that's a better
topic
i had
spent just a very short period of time
when i had been
award
uh when i had been a photojournalist
in uh el salvador and honduras and so
that experience had led me enough to
know that it would be
interesting personalities and as well as
an interesting subject was was this was
this the this book then an offshoot from
your dissertation
i wrote the dissertation and then
uh spent about a year revising it making
it
a more accessible uh
more interesting book than the
dissertation probably was
when was the first time you can remember
picking up a camera
when i was
a little more than a toddler maybe
can you remember why you did it or what
the influence was on your
family well it was one of those kodak
and thematics you know the sort of black
plastic ones that if
you drop they shattered in a million
pieces
and the first photographs i remember
taking
was at the new york world's fair in 1964
and 65.
uh i was not very old
[Music]
and
but i was aware at that age that it was
a historic occasion and i think
in some elementary school fashion i
wanted to document it i wanted to to say
okay
this is an event that i was at and these
are
the united states pavilion you know this
was whatever the pavilions were that
that seemed
seemed interesting
did you have a family that was was
interested in art or
photography
uh
we were always being taken to to museums
uh sort of all over
and both my mother my grandmother
were artists of
some small
some small talent and i had an
aunt who was quite a well-known painter
so it was it was in the family
when was the first time he actually had
a job as a photographer
photojournalist well as a photographer
that would have been between
after i graduated from undergraduate
school actually here in washington
i started out and
i let me think probably what was the
first job
i think what it was is i was hired by a
coalition of groups
who had some bills coming up in congress
that were to protect migrant workers
and they wanted someone to go around the
country to photograph
migrant worker camps
migrant workers in the field so they
could use
the
the reportage i would also be writing as
well as the images to use as a senate
testimony
and
i had already been working with these
groups
as sort of a writer and consultant
so i added photography to it and thereby
a career was born have you ever been a
combat photographer
no
a few times i've photographed sort of
the aftermath of it but
i've never
never been there when the shelling
shelling is going on
one of the most interesting things in
the prologue was a reference to anne
frank
compared her to what
photographers
i mean there was a comparison why the
why the comparison why is anne frank and
what what is a photographer think have
in common right well
often i get the question what's a nice
girl like you doing in a subject like
this
and
people when they think of war
photography all they think of is the
horror and the grimness
but
despite the
the inherent grimness of the subject
there's something that's fundamentally
positive
about
the process and the the process of
photographing war and the
the prince the photographic prince
themselves
and that's where the connection to anne
frank comes in because i think war
photographers
really like anne frank believe that
people are really good at heart
and that if you can only show
enough people
what's really happening
that somehow in some small way
what's really happening
may happen better there may be some
change
is there a start is there a thread that
runs through
most of the photographers you've known
in the way their personality their
political interests
on and on well
yes and no there's
let me think
there's photographers who
are apolitical they're photographers
who are
quite political from a liberal
perspective or from a conservative
perspective
there are some photographers who are
very articulate some who
are very visually oriented and perhaps
aren't so
verbal
but i think if you did have to pick a
thread it would be
this one that i mentioned this
belief that it's important
to document the world uh and
particularly
this this aspect of the world
when you go out or when you have some
free time to play with your camera
what do you shoot first of all what kind
of camera do you use i use olympus
equipment
35 millimeter 35 millimeter
if you've got free time to shoot
whatever you can what do you what was
your favorite subject
always something with people in it
uh i've never been someone who's
particularly interested in sort of
abstract landscapes or
cityscapes
if i would be shooting at a
family event or something like that i'd
be more interested in
people's emotions people's interaction
and those are also the same kind of
images i think that i was particularly
drawn to
of the war photographs it was not those
that were
of the
destruction of buildings or
the more static pictures of of armaments
stacked up or whatever but were those
that attempted to describe
the soldiers of the civilians experience
how long did it take you to write this
book
uh longer than i thought but shorter
than
shorter than you might think
it was two years
as a graduate student
and then another year of revision when
you finish it
has it ever finished uh
i guess more or less last year i mean
even when i was doing
so page proofs and galley proofs and so
forth there's still
footnotes you want to add in or you
realize that this is not quite right so
you're thinking with it so all told it
was really four years
but three years of
staple to the computer writing
how did you go about putting this book
together and how many wars
did you cover
well that's a good question
there are five wars
starting with the spanish american war
and moving more or less up to the
present so it's
the spanish-american war world war one
world war ii korea and vietnam
and then there's a short epilogue about
grenada and a very short couple page
prologue about civil war
people have often asked me when i've
traveled around giving lectures as to
why i didn't start with the civil war
because most americans when they think
of
a book that attempts to look at war
photography
they they think of matthew brady's
famous photographs from the civil war
but what i was particularly interested
in this book
was in showing
how
americans how we at home
saw war i'm not interested really in all
the war photographs that were ever taken
i'm interested in those that those of us
sitting in our armchairs in the living
room see
well the spanish american war was the
first war that was really seen at home
if you want to put it that was the first
living room war
and the reason for that is that
in the late 1880s and the late 1890s
spanish civil spanish american war was
in 1898
was when the half ton was invented it's
a process that we still use today it's a
process of how we get photographs into
print what does a half tone process mean
a half tone means that you take a
photograph print like you'd get back
from
the photo store
and you
superimpose a dot pattern on it
so if you took a magnifying glass to
your
daily newspaper
you'd see
the blacks would have
dots very close together and the lighter
areas would have dots very far apart
it's a way
of
it's a way of simply printing printing a
photographic print without using a
continuous tone
and that process started when well it
was actually invented in 1888 but it
wasn't adapted
for use by the mass market press in
other words they couldn't really put it
on those big rollers that the
the newsprint goes through
until the mid-1890s so it was only
really before
right immediately before the
spanish-american war that photographs
gone to print
so
you decided to go to the
spanish-american war and you went to
what kind of publications
photography books
no i went to the publications
same kind of publications that i went to
throughout throughout the 20th century
which are
mass-market
national market publications
well some
those of those of your audience who
maybe are my age or older may remember
collier's magazine
which only died in the 1960s
made its name
from the photography from the
spanish-american war
scribner's magazine harpers
names that are still
in some households at least household
names
and many of these
for the first time instead of sending
illustrators to cover an event
a lot of these publications had since
harper's had been in existence more or
less since the
since before the civil war but in the
civil war they sent
artists like winslow homer to the
battlefield to take drawings and those
were in turn turned into engravings
on the spanish-american war
the various publications sent down both
illustrators
and photographers into
into combat so you had an illustrator
such as frederick remington the famous
western artist
uh who went down to
cover the
theater roosevelt and his charge up san
juan hill at the same time you had very
famous photographers like richard
harding davis or jimmy hare
let's look at we've got a lot of photos
to look at in this hour and for our
viewers that just joined us we're
talking with the author of this book
called shooting war
susan muller is her name and you're
currently at princeton i'm teaching
history of princeton what kind of
history
well i teach american history for the
most part uh i'm also
have taught a couple courses actually
one course over in the
american studies department but i
primarily teach
20th century history the biosheet says
that you have a phd and a master's from
harvard and an undergraduate degree from
yale
yeah clean sweep i guess
that you uh were born where in new
jersey
i was actually born in a hospital in
east orange and my family lived in west
orange and my grandparents lived in
south orange and you grew up in belgium
belgium and switzerland where and why
well
i didn't last too long in new jersey we
almost immediately
moved to outside of philadelphia and
then my
more or less at the end of elementary
school my father was transferred he's a
businessman was transferred overseas to
belgium and i went to school a little
bit south of brussels belgium and then
my senior year in high school we moved
to switzerland to geneva so it was a
great way to grow up how many
photographs are in the book
well there are 40 pages i think there's
60
odd photographs and you you've numbered
them all
consecutively so that we can communicate
with our uh producer on this program
we'll not we'll call for the numbers and
then you can describe to us what this
photo is all about first one up we'll
take the number one photograph and this
is from the spanish-american war
see it on the screen right there what's
this all about
well
this was a photograph of probably
it looks like a heap of laundry
but it's really one of the most famous
photographs in the spanish-american war
it's the picture
of two dead rough riders and your
viewers may recall that theodore
roosevelt was probably the most famous
of the rough riders it's
it's the role that propelled him into
the white house and the man on the left
you can barely see he's got hobnail
boots
sticking out from under those blankets
the
is a man named hamilton fish jr and his
father was secretary of state under uh
grant i believe
he had volunteered for the war
volunteered and
anyway had been killed in the very first
battle that the rough riders were in
the reason why this this photograph is
particularly
important is one because it depicts
as much as you can see it the the body
of
probably the most famous person who was
killed during the war
but
it's also i think an indication
of
how the photographers felt about
the
men who were killed during the war
often we tend to think about wars in
cliches world war one was the war to end
all wars and so forth well the the
litany for
the spanish-american war was
was a war for duty and destiny
and the sense
it was probably actually the most
popular war in american history more
popular than even world war ii
and the sense was that this was
everyone's chance for for glory
and when the photographers went to cuba
to photograph the war
they
took photographs that
protected the soldiers nobility they
didn't want to show pictures of
men bloodied by combat
this particular photograph that
particular photograph of the two
bodies under the heaps of blankets the
photographer who took that made the
conscious choice
he covered the bodies up
made the conscious choice to photograph
them that way so the viewers at home his
audience
wouldn't
be able to gawk
that war lasted how many days
boy just a couple weeks
let's look at photograph number three
all right
this is a uh this is actually photograph
there's photograph number
number two this is this number three in
the book this is number three in the
book okay
this
is
those same two bodies
uh in the foreground there again you can
see sort of the man's hobnail boots
sticking out from one of the blankets in
the background
is a
circle of officers this is taking place
before another battle
and the man in the sort of the dark
shirt he's got cross suspenders on the
far right is theodore roosevelt
this was a photograph that was not
allowed to be published
and the reason why
is because
in this photograph you see
men
talking and laughing as if the two dead
boys don't exist and that was considered
to be
unthinkable
that you didn't
um you had respect for the dead
let's look at photograph number seven
all right
we please have photograph number seven
this is a sort of a classic
war photograph i think many of us when
we think of
wars in in years gone by maybe we've
seen movies from
uh
of waterloo or whatever the civil war
and this is what we think of we think of
cannons
and billowing smoke
this is a picture uh from one of the
artillery engagements during uh the war
uh the big wagon wheel you see is
attached to a cannon and the reason why
everything is so light in the sort of
upper right is because it's the
billowing billowing cannon smoke
and this is i think indicative of the
kind of
photograph that
the photographers wanted to take it was
a very romantic view of war
but perhaps the other reason to mention
it is because the only
images of combat
that really exist for the spanish
american war you have to remember that
at this point
there was
the camera equipment
was very slow was very large and didn't
have the kind of fast film
and perhaps long lenses that we are used
to now
so there are no pictures of theater rose
about charging up the san juan hills
there are no pictures of
men jumping out of trenches or whatever
the only photographs we have that one
could consider combat are those of sort
of cannons firing how many photographers
did you find that
that were involved in the world in the
spanish american war
more than you might think uh i think it
was
hmm
uh
i remember there were
probably a couple hundred
but of those i i may be misstating i'm
not sure i remember my own facts here
but of that number
as was true for all wars even though
there may be a lot of photographers only
a handful were really critical
there were very few
outlets for photography as i mentioned
it was a very
new technological phenomenon
and so the outlets
for photographers were really in
cities like new york now the three
photographs we saw were all taken by the
same photographer
no uh two the first two were taken by
one photographer and
mcintosh brew macintosh yes anything
interesting about him
well not especially except he was one of
the first photographers to come down
with yellow fever
there are many more soldiers who were
killed during the spanish american war
because of yellow fever
than because of
the actual combat injuries
and
the reason why he came down with yellow
fever is
that when the
uh the troop ships arrived off the coast
of cuba
the correspondents were not allowed to
go on shore with the troops and burr
mcintosh wanted to get a photograph of
the men
striding ashore
and he smuggled his cameras into one of
the men's boats
and had them row his cameras ashore and
then he
dove
over the deck and swam into shore
not realizing how far he was out and
also the undertow was going the wrong
direction by the time he got into shore
he was pretty exhausted and his health
was more or less shot so he's a prime
candidate for coming down with
with fever the last photo that we just
saw was william denwoodies i believe and
who was he
i probably know less about him he on the
other hand was
was one of the better photographers
of the war um
and
was a
photographer that was used both in i
think some of the major
magazines like scriveners and harper's
and so forth
what happened to photography between
1898 and the beginning of world war ii
was about 1916
world war one i mean world war one i'm
sorry
well
cameras got slightly smaller slightly
faster
but it was more
less the technology
although that was important but more
that the photographers had learned how
to photograph war
right after the spanish-american war
there were several other national
conflict or international conflicts
there was the the boer war
the russo-japanese war
boxer rebellion so photographers
were jaunting around the world and and
they realized that
they could not use the large format
cameras that they
had taken to the spanish-american war
many of them can you show us with using
your hands how big that camera was in
the spanish-american war
well
many of the photographers in the smash
american war used an eight by a camera
that took eight by ten negatives so just
think of a
you know eight and a half by 11 sheet of
paper was more or less that size not
only that but there were glass plates
so you can imagine how careful someone
had to be and also if you're carrying
20 grass plates how heavy that was
so
what the
photographers had learned between
the spanish american war in world war
one was that it was just untenable to
carry that larger camera what they
really needed to do was go down to the
smaller format cameras which which were
available
um
the largest would be five by seven and
more to be
even smaller maybe
sort of index card size
let's take a look at some of the photos
from world war one and the first one up
i believe is photo number 11.
this is a photograph of an uh of a
burial of an american officer there you
can see that the casket covered with the
stars and stripes and there are sort of
few narrow wreaths
in front of the coffin
the honor guard standing behind it this
is the burial of one of the first men
killed
after the united states entered the war
which was of course in 1917
the reason for this
for for showing this picture is
to demonstrate the absolute blanket
censorship that
was
in
in operation during world war one there
was
throughout the entire war from 14 to 18
it was not allowed you were not allowed
to show
any pictures of american dead or even
the allied dead any pictures of american
wounded
unless the wounded were already
receiving aid and unless
they were totally cleaned up in other
words you could not show pictures with
with blood with people with
perhaps a missing limb or so
uh
you also saw very few pictures of combat
most the pictures
were
as i said absolutely absolutely censored
the idea being
that
none of the the powers that be whether
they would be american or french or even
the the central powers germany austria
and so forth
wanted to
inform the public at home exactly what
was happening on the fighting front as
you as we all know from from hindsight
how how absolutely bloody a war it was
well as you can imagine the concern of
the military authorities
was that if the public at home
saw exactly what was happening in the
fighting front that all support for the
war effort would totally dissipate
kail and
herbert the name of the the two
photographers that took that picture now
katelyn herbert
uh like
another group called underwood and
underwood are two of the most prominent
pitcher agencies
that were in existence
most of the photographs
are anonymous or anonymous in as much as
we don't know who took the pictures
uh that was another
effect of the censorship that you didn't
know who took the pictures the pictures
that did appear in the publications were
released often months after the event
they pictured
and the captions themselves were very
obscure would never identify
an individual officer
would never identify an individual place
he would not see
americans with the eiffel tower in the
background because they didn't want to
show that americans were in paris for
example next photo is 17 underwood and
underwood agency what's this
oh i think this is one of the the sort
of humorous quietly humorous photographs
of the war this is
uh i
believe titled something the effect of
uh
americans ready for a gas attack
they look like bugs but they're wearing
gas masks
and this was an example of the kind of
photography the kind of photograph that
was passed off as combat photographs to
us it looks like
if you take their masks away they're
posing for some sort of high school
yearbook
doesn't look like they're anywhere near
ready to go into combat
but this was
about as close to the the fighting lines
as
we saw during the war itself
next photo was centered evening post
october 9th 1918 another underwood and
underwood
photo and we ought to have it up here if
we don't i'll show i think we have it
right let's look at it here in the book
that i've got
uh here we go
yeah this is
i think one of the the best and most
successful pictures
of the war
i think this is the way that we
as
historians
or we as as
as learning from history think about
world war one we think of
men going over the top men going over
there
laden down with the sort of knapsacks
and and and the guns and that those
funny little bold shaped helmets
but this was not
as i said before this is not indicative
of the photographs uh from the war it's
it's
an anomaly that
we saw anything as i said again this
close to the front or
or even this compositionally well
uh well contrived
if our audience is just joining us i
want to tell them who we're talking with
and what we're talking about it's a book
called
shooting war looks like this and its
author
is susan mohler
and we're talking about uh photography
or photography from five wars spanish
american war world war one which we just
completed
uh and we have three wars to go which
was your favorite war from a photography
standpoint
i think would have to be the world war
ii or vietnam
because i think the photographs from
those wars were the most
outstanding
and also i because there were the
there were also the wars
well world war one world war two rather
was the war in which i was able to begin
to interview
some
of the photographers themselves uh
so it's always more interesting not only
when i
can look at the photographs as they
appeared but can say all right mr carl
maidens uh
how did you take this picture what were
you thinking of did you talk to anybody
who was a photographer in the spanish
american war
no actually while i was riding the
spanish-american war the very last
survivor who was not a photographer but
was um
some
uh teenager who had lied his way into
fighting the spanish american war he
died at the age of 109
and he died while i was writing that
chapter how about world war one anybody
that was a photographer in world war one
you've been able to i did talk to a
couple of the photographers who were in
the signal core
photographic division
and many of the photographs from well
from all the wars
were military photographers
many of the even the civilian
publications whether it be the new york
times or
time in newsweek did use
military
photography
and i did in this in world war one talk
to some military photographers but
as far as i know all the civilian
photographers had had died by the time
that i was writing the book do you
happen to recall right off top your head
how many people were killed and
americans were killed in spanish
american war and world war one
each war
oh boy
numbers are not my strong suit that's
why i didn't go into math
any
overall uh
you know
how how many
well in something something the effect
in the spanish-american war it's
something the effect of
including the philippines and including
all those who are killed by disease it's
it's less than five thousand um
and world war one hmm
i'm gonna have some military buffs down
in my head i i'm not gonna hazard a
guess okay here's world war two and the
first photo we're going to look at is
number 22 i believe
first of all before you explain this had
cameras changed a great deal between
world war one and world war ii
yes what had really happened was a 35
millimeter camera had come in
many of the
uh
photographers who
we associate most of the world war one
world war ii rather
were
using the new 35 millimeter cameras
leica cameras and context cameras there
were still some larger format cameras uh
two and a quarter cameras that were
being used speed graphic was sort of a
classic
but
almost all the photographs that we
remember from life magazine for example
were 35 millimeter cameras and what that
meant was
that photographers were freer than they
ever had been before they could take
pictures under
um
all kinds of lighting circumstances
because the film was faster they could
take pictures
uh you know at the dusk in the dawn as
well as in the bright and the bright
light of daytime when did color come in
actually there are some uh color
photographs from world war ii uh
there's some from the italian front i
believe
well some both in the italian front and
from the pacific
let's go back to the photos and we're
gonna have to go through these kind of
quickly so we can get through the the
next three wars here is that photograph
again what's this all about
well this is probably
in a way the most pivotal photograph
from the war it was printed in september
1943 and the reason it's pivotal life
magazine life magazine yes the reason
it's pivotal is that was
one of the first three photographs that
were released of the american dead so
it's the first time in
50 years that americans saw americans
who've been killed in combat
up to that
1943 date
censorship for world war ii was the same
as for world war one you couldn't show
graphic pictures of of any kind
23 this is joe rosenthal
this is the classic photograph taken by
joe rosenthal of ap of the flag being
raised on mount suribashi and on iwo
jima
and i think the one point to say here is
that it is not a fake
it is a second
a picture of the second flag raising on
iwo jima
but
it is a legitimate unposed photograph of
the second flag raising and the reason
for a second flag being raised was the
first flag that was ra that was raised
was very small
and fighting was still going on on the
island
and the admiral in charge of the
fighting wanted a larger flag from the
ships so that all the
all the
the soldiers could be inspired by the
american flag so they brought up a
larger flag to raise
this next one
24 is kind of rough isn't it
it's a tough photograph it's one of the
last from the war it's it's probably the
last combat picture
in many ways
from the european front
it's a photograph of an american soldier
killed in the very last day of the war
against germany in 1945
and it's from a series of photographs
very last one
taken by probably the most famous war
photographer of all robert kappa
why is he the most famous
well maybe because he uh
had the most charismatic personality he
was also the photographer you might see
a picture of his later
that
uh
was most famous for his pictures of the
normandy d-day invasion
25.
uh 25
is a classic example of how americans
use photography to stereotype their
enemies
particularly americans
had a campaign to
rev up hate against
the japanese enemy
and use photographs such as this to
legitimate the kind of caricatured still
uh stereotypes that we're more used to
seeing in the sort of poster campaigns
this is a navy photographer navy
photograph
uh
i believe so uh says it was published in
newsweek publisher newsweek um yeah it
was a military photograph
and here you have the classics of
bare-chested square jaw american
with his rifle trained on a rather
myopic they have the round glasses
bucktooth receding gin
chin uh japanese soldier an attempt by
the americans to show you know sort of
the prime physical specimen of americans
and the sort of the rather the weak
degenerate
humans that characterize the japanese
race
what's happening to this period you
talked about earlier that you had
scribners and harpers and colliers and
now we see a little bit of life magazine
we didn't talk about this in world war
one what other new publications did you
start finding as you
move through the early part of this
century
well in the 1920s you have the creation
of what we might call the news magazines
which would be time and news week and so
forth those publications that use
photographs a lot but are text heavy
then in the mid-1930s you have
life and look
and it's really those four magazines
that continue
from the 1930s up really to the present
day to dominate
americans
coverage of of war and coverage of
world events this next photograph again
is from world war ii and it's your 26th
photograph and it's done by ralph morris
what is this
well this is maybe the most horrific
photograph from the book and it is a
photograph from guadalcanal of a
japanese skull that sort of
speared on top of a japanese tank
when i interviewed him about this he
mentioned that he was with a
platoon of soldiers who
were walking through the jungle came out
into a clearing and saw this and he took
it
saw this
the scene and he took the picture of it
it was published in life
and perhaps created
the greatest amount of fury of any
photograph in the war
we see
a lot of support from people as well as
a concerted outcry from
from others
this is uh photograph number 33
this is
perhaps a photograph that shows
the kind of
of care the kind of
patriotism
symbolism that was still evident and
still operating in
uh in world war ii
the caption to this was crucified to a
stretcher and here we have a man who was
not only
literally crucified in the crucifix
position with his arms outstretched but
is actually wearing a crucifix
it's it's a i think a good example of
how photography could could capture the
symbolism
and this was in look magazine this was
in look magazine and it was a u.s marine
corps photographer yes that's correct
35. uh that famous photograph from
robert kappa that i was telling you
about earlier uh
of the normandy d-day invasion of the
barely make-out there's a man crawling
ashore and those sort of spiky looking
things in the background are tank traps
did you say earlier i apologize i didn't
hear you did you say robert kappa died
in the war no robert kappa died in 1954
as perhaps one of the very first victims
of the indo-china war he was
photographing
the french indochina war
right before the siege of dien benfu
and he was killed by mine
and
you said that he was your favorite
well i'm not sure whether he's exactly
my favorite but he's he's certainly one
of my favorites he's but i think that he
is perhaps the most the most well-known
of all the photographers uh who've ever
covered war
at least in this century move on to the
korean war and what changed between
world war ii and the korean war in the
photography field
well not much changed except that you
did now have the introduction of the
nikon camera
and what that meant is you had a very
a camera that
could accommodate a lot of different
kinds of lenses so you begin to have for
the first time
japanese camera japanese camera a wide
use of telephoto lenses wide angle
lenses
so in other words it's much easier to
take close-ups
of men in combat without actually
sitting on top of of the soldiers
themselves what happened to color
well color was
around but was
almost never used in the korean war
actually probably less than it was in
world war ii it was not really until the
1960s in vietnam that you really begin
to see color
i think the big difference between korea
and world war ii
was less that the technology had changed
and more that
american attitudes towards the war
itself had changed world war ii was the
war that everyone felt needed to be
fight fought it was a good war
but
the korean war
people had much more ambivalent feelings
about
so the photographs that came back
mirrored this ambivalence let's look at
photograph number 39
this is one of the very first
photographs to come out of korea it's a
photograph of a american pow who's been
dressed up with a telephone wire and has
been assassinated the side of a road
it's an army u.s army photo u.s army
photograph had appeared
in several publications
and
as you can imagine it horrified the
country it was one thing to see
americans killed in action
it was another thing to see americans
who seemed like they've been killed in
cold blood
photo number 42
department of defense photo
well this i think is an excellent
example of what i was telling you about
the difference between
how
americans felt about world war ii and
how they felt about korea
when this photograph appeared in
newsweek
a letter wrote a writer wrote in after
it appeared and said
this is the photograph from korea just
like the flag raising on iwo jima is the
photograph from world war ii well the
iwo jima photograph of the flag raising
is a photograph of
it's very patriotic very heroic
photograph and this photograph that
photograph is much more of a
photograph that's it's compassionate but
not heroic
hank walker who is he
hank walker was a staff member of life
magazine and that's photo number 48 in
your book
photograph number 48
is perhaps a good example of some of the
photography from korean war
that looked ahead to the vietnam war it
was unusual in korea
to see
it's it's
the picture depicts an american training
his gun on
some
chinese communists who are there lying
in the ditch in their sort of quilted
clothing i think it's it's
an example oh i was going to say that
inquiry it's very rare to see such a
distinct landscape the kind of of
landscape that we were
going to see very frequently
in vietnam you talked to hank walker no
i didn't is he still alive
you caught me on that one
i'm not sure i i don't believe he is but
i don't want to kill him off prematurely
let's look at margaret burke white
and this is your final photograph from
the korean war 49
well this again is
in some ways a forward-looking
photograph to to
uh vietnam
because margaret burke white
was one of the
the most famous and also one of the very
few women photographers in the war and
she also was one of the few
photographers who was
who was interested in
part of the korean war that didn't
receive much attention which was the
guerrilla war
this is a photograph of
a south korean soldiers
carrying
a dead
guerrilla
north korean gorilla who's being brought
back to headquarters in order to be
identified
we don't tend to tend to associate
guerrilla war with korea with a korean
conflict but there was indeed
a major sort of guerrilla component to
it
i guess it's my age but the photos that
i remember this next war
my age too
do you find as you talk to people that
people had just as strong a memory about
korean war and world war ii as say i
would have about the vietnam war well i
think it probably depends on who you
talk to uh
i do think that
vietnam war maybe because
it's the most recent war and also in
some ways is the most visual
war
related related to it
primarily visually that people
do tend to associate
when they first think of war they call
up vietnam images
what happened to photography you had the
nikon in korea anything new happened by
the time the vietnam war came around
just really a proliferation of different
kinds of 35 millimeter cameras instead
of only having um
the nikon cameras from japan and the
leica cameras from germany he began to
have minolta's and
so there were
proliferation of equipment
color
color was used
uh
yes for the first time and particularly
in the 1960s when money was no object
color was used lavishly
and what's the reason that you didn't
put any color in your book
well unfortunately that's uh
financial considerations uh
it's a
it's a big book we wanted people to be
able to afford it
it does make a big difference to print
color it does make a big difference in
print color although
as i suggested
many of the very famous photographs from
vietnam were not in color actually i
think there's only
three photographs that should be in
color that we had to translate into
black and white
the reason for so many black and white
photographs that were taken during the
war was that the wire services whether
it's ap and upi
uh which who transmitted their
photographs
through the air more or less
they couldn't use they couldn't use
color or at least it took much longer to
transmit color photographs so they
always shot in black and white so many
of the famous photographs we remember
from the war and we'll see a few coming
up uh were originally in black and white
as it is your book is 25.95 no no no no
don't make it worse than it is it's
25.95 what did i say 29.95 i thought i
said 25.95 uh that's expensive book
though isn't it
well it's about i think the upper the
upper end of the the trade press but uh
yeah you get a lot of photographs and
you get a lot of you get a lot of
information so is the photograph the
number of photographs the reason why
it's more expensive yes
and it's done by basic books and what
did you think of your publisher
they were great uh they really have been
both
from the
beginning stages of helping me
edit the book and conceptualize
changing it from a dissertation into
a book
that the man on the street might be
interested in reading they were helpful
and they've been very helpful
more recently in helping me publicize
and market it vietnam
photograph number 50 larry burrows
what's this larry burroughs is probably
the photographer from the war
he was an englishman a very
gentle man
who
tragically was killed as a result of the
war he was one of many war
correspondents who was killed
he was killed in
a helicopter accident over laos
but the reason for showing this
photograph is not only that it's
it's
a photograph probably from his most
famous photo essay that appeared in life
magazine in 1965
the photograph of of
a photograph from a series
on a helicopter crew one day in the life
of a helicopter crew
but i think this photograph
is
a very good example of how technological
war had become
and
that was a good example of the combat
photographs from world war
i i mean sorry from from vietnam but we
didn't see that kind of technology
evident in the previous wars that we
were seeing no that was life magazine
and here's another one from life
magazine which is uh photograph number
51.
well this was in line well this is not
the right one they've got we've got the
wrong one here let me show you what
photograph 51 is right here and see what
uh
explain this one well this was one of
the ones in color uh
that photograph that you're putting up
on the screen there was originally
cropped
the woman who is the photographer
at the right of your picture
was cropped out of the photograph right
here uh this is another larry dress this
is another larry burroughs uh photograph
and uh it's the evacuation of a they're
running up to an lz a landing zone for a
helicopter come down and airlift this
this man back
behind the lines
next photograph is photograph number 53
i believe we'll have it on the screen
here in just a moment what's this
uh this is not 53 by the way uh let me
again i think we've got them all out of
sequel go ahead and explain this one
we'll get the rest of what's this one
right here uh this is i think one of the
three or four classic photographs of the
war um
55 55.
it's a photograph of a little naked girl
running down the running down the road
in anne locke
she's just torn her claws off because
there was a napalm strike
and
this is published in the new york times
june 9th 1972
and
the name on it is
nick
nick
who is a
photographer who was
photographing for ap
and
i think it's it's one of the photographs
that those of us who lived through the
war
remember when we think of the war
it's one of the icons you want to put it
that way
of the vietnam war this next one is also
memorable at least for may 53 by malcolm
brown who
it says here was with the philadelphia
inquirer now with the uh no it happened
to it appeared
uh
it appeared in the philadelphia inquirer
this was
a photograph from 1963 of a furnace
buddhist monk uh setting himself a flame
in the streets to protest
the government
and ap photo ap photograph malcolm brown
worked for ap uh
he then several years later worked for
abc and then returned to vietnam
actually was
working for abc in vietnam and then
returned working for the new york times
where he still is
but that photograph being one of the
first graphic images from
vietnam was not
pictured everywhere um the very first
photograph we saw that little naked girl
running down the road
that was in the front pages of all the
newspapers around the world
as was this quite famous photograph
from uh the tet offensive in 1968
which was
taken by eddie adams
also of ap
a photograph of the self of a south
vietnamese general
shooting a alleged vietcom lieutenant
how controversial was this photograph
when it was published
well it was very controversial
for all all kinds of reasons
it raised
questions about
how far should photography go
how how much should the media show us
but more importantly than the
journalistic issues it raised it raised
questions about the war
was this was a war that condoned
that kind of action was that a war that
americans wanted to participate in
i can't even remember this 20 years
later that it was general loan it was
general loan i mean did that have that
kind of an impact on all yes yes i
really did
okay this probably is next uh
i don't know if we have it i've got it
here in the book uh let's go to 56 and
it looks like this uh bobby why don't
you bring come down here on 56. all
right
what's this
well that's
one of the most famous photographs from
the milan massacre
and
i think all of these last four images
we've shown um this mile massacre
photograph the photograph of the naked
little girl the photograph of the man
being shot in the middle of the street
the photograph of the burning monk
if you recall all of them they all are
pictures of vietnamese civilians
and this is very unusual vietnam was the
first war in which we saw photographs of
civilians in any number at all
and the reason for this
is that it was a way
that the press had of commenting on the
war
it was a way of showing the american
public look this is what
we're not only
killing enemy soldiers
it's not only american soldiers as well
that are being killed but we're also
injuring women and children
sort of a moral commentary i think one
of the reasons why these photographs
made such an impression
is because they did deal with civilians
they dealt with the victims of war
ron haberly ron haberly
still alive still alive
talk to him
no he's a hard man to reach and you can
understand why he doesn't want to
talk too much about why not
well i i just kept getting letters that
were sent back
so i'm not i can't i can't really answer
that um he did
have some interviews
very shortly
after
the photographs came out
but i think he's
tried to remain private since then did
you find a lot of that when he tried to
reach some of the photographers from the
vietnam war no actually with
with
no other exceptions did i have any
difficulty in speaking to photographers
malcolm brown the one who did the
photographer who who took the burning
monk shot
eddie adams who took the
assassination shot the execution shot
both of those photographers for example
i talked to and larry burroughs who took
the first two photographs that we saw
from viet from vietnam
uh
although as i mentioned he's no longer
alive
his son and his wife were very helpful
in opening up his
notebooks and files and speaking to me
about
uh his experiences during the war i want
to look at the last photograph for
this hour and that's another larry
burroughs photograph what's this
uh
this is a photograph
of um
well it's very
it's very close to
uh i think it's operation prairie
you have the date in front of you it's
february 26 1971 71 and uh
was actually taken back i believe in
1966 this photograph as it
as a caption appears in the book
was
released in life magazine as part of the
memorial issue
that was dedicated to larry burroughs
after he had been killed in laos
uh in this photograph i think is
perhaps most notable for the
relationship that's that's created here
between the black soldier on the left
and the white soldier on the right
although
blacks and other minorities participated
overwhelmingly in the war and were
overwhelmingly
on the front lines as well there are
relatively few images that came back
showing blacks and showing minorities
and
many of the photographs that did come
back tended to emphasize
the harmonious relations between the
races
rather than emphasize perhaps
conflict that might also have been
mentioned do you have a favorite
photograph in this whole series we
looked at
boy
that's a tough question
it's like asking a mother whether she
has a favorite child
no i don't think i do
when are you the most intrigued by a
photograph
well
i guess that i'm most
interested in looking at photographs in
context i have a tough time
walking into magazines
and walking rather into museums and
seeing photographs
out of context on the wall as images of
art if they were originally taken
as as journalism so i'm most interested
in photographs
in the original context looking at them
in life magazine or looking at them in
harper's magazine or any of these other
now defunct publications seeing
where they were in the page was the
headline what was the caption
seeing them as the public at the time
saw them
our guest for the last hour and it did
go very quickly susan mohler
who is the
author of this book called shooting war
you see right here
and
she is
among other things a graduate of harvard
university where she's got both a phd
and a master's
a graduate of yale where she got her
undergraduate degree and currently
teaches at princeton where she's been
for the last couple years
teaching history and she is also
a photographer in her own right thank
you very much for your time thank you
sir
[Music]
join us each sunday night when we'll
bring you this series of interviews with
the authors of recent books that's
sundays at 8 pm eastern time 5 p.m
pacific and coming up next on c-span a
look at the week ahead on capitol hill
[Music]
[Music]
you